ich darf ihnen auch namen von frau
professor djk heute präsentieren wie wir
uns in der versorgenden wäre engagieren
wir sind dass es vielen unternehmen hier
natürlich bekannt mit zwei prominenten
eben auch programm verankert zum einen
eben das multiplikator und wo wir eins
zu eins 2016 mittlerweile in der dritten
runde und darüber hinaus ihm auch nicht
mit einem learning projekt bei lehrer
ndr/2006 frau professor ludger muss sie
ganz herzlich kann heute leider nicht
hier sein müssen vortragen auch
gemeinschaft nicht bestritten
sie hat eine andere veranstaltung ein
experimental aktuell mögliches projekt
wo es darum geht herauszufinden mit
welchen machen wir nicht man in der
halle gekocht hat zu diesem zweck musste
heute früh nach wien fahren mit dem
auftauchen voller dieses tor nicht
aus den gästen ganz abbrechen mussten
ja die frau professorin überleitung
geschaffen in dem sport das sagt
mahlzeit in der welt oder auch schon da
und soll es eben 8
und in der tat und möchte ich ihnen
jetzt einen zumindest einen blick auf
das große ganze presse bekommen möchte
ich spiele einfach zeigen welche
erfahrungen wir einfach gemacht haben
mit der etablierung vorne ja für die
verbesserung der lehre welche
ausgangssituation wir hatten wie hier
vorgegangen sind die wirklichen grund
unserer beziehung operation investiert
haben mit rechnen auch wenn wir zusammen
gearbeitet haben möchte braucht dass ich
ihnen das wir ihnen eine reihe von
anknüpfungspunkten auch zum beispiel ist
in diskussion können das ist eine ganze
reihe von stichwort werden die eine
rolle spielen werden die schon gäste
waren in der diskussion aber auch hier
nicht gefallen sind lernspiele die
einbindung von studierenden bei der
erstellung von
karten erhalten nachhaltigkeit ist ein
wichtiges nicht nur das ding kann nicht
das was sich entwickelt habe eben auch
verstehen klicken
das soll es an alles themen zur sprache
kommen und wir bieten ihnen runde einen
genauen einigung wie wir das versucht
haben zu setzen oder versuchen werden
umzusetzen denn würden es in der
natürlich mittendrin
ich werde deswegen tatsächlich auch
anfangen mit den ferien also den
multiplikatoren projekt und ihnen dann
zeigen die wir einfach in einer zweiten
phase dieses weiter geführt haben und
ihnen aufzuzeigen was wir noch machen
wollen in zukunft kurzem ist die
ausgangslage
womit wir umgehen müssen sind im grunde
herausforderungen die symptomatische
kleine fächer sind die gegend welcher
also mit wenigen hauptwerks bedienenden
und seine kollegen auf nicht an
diese masse von einem ebenfalls
studierende die ägyptologie ist ein
ausgesprochenes lernen fach das heißt
wir unsere untersuchungstisch dank der
beschränkten sich zwar auf das alte
ägypten
aber das ist ein zeitraum von über 5.000
jahren das ist die vision recht
außergewöhnlich auch völlig mit anderen
historischen futuristischen disziplin
dass es eben ein immenser zeit haben ist
da wenn die ägypter nicht mehr
übertragen können sie im amt gewesen aus
den hinterlassenschaften und die sind
endlos und unglaublich vielfältig das
umgehen mit architektur und beginnt und
wird mit flachbild mitte dagegen mit
texten und so weiter und so fort und
decken und kunde auch alle themen an
politischer kultur geschichte auch in
unserer rostock und auch in der lehre
das heißt die politische sich das
königtum kürzungsvorschlägen
antrags leben sozialgeschichte religion
all das lehren und forschen wir auch und
das leben in einer serie müssen die
grundlegenden informationen zu
allerdings in bereichen wie man das sehr
begrenzte zeit an unsere studierenden
leben vermitteln
das ist der eine punkt der zweite punkt
mit dem wir immer alles aus ist auch ein
kleines fach zu operieren haben ist die
heterogenität unsere studierenden das
ist natürlich dass unsere übergewichtung
dass wir nicht nur uns auch in der lehre
auch zum wm aus studierenden die blutung
im kopf zu konzentrieren sondern wir
haben müssen eben in einer ganzen reihe
von noch breiten nebenfächern beteiligt
wie an die konturen oder sprache kultur
und literatur und kultur und so weiter
und so fort
das heißt wir haben dann veranstaltungen
mit sieben teilnehmern haben autos aus
auch veranstaltungen mit 60 teilnehmern
plus mit denen wir einfach umgehen
müssen und wie können
besonders an den brauch bei dem leben
nach studierenden zwar interesse für den
gegenstand voraussetzen aber keine form
ist und empfangsteile und wo wir im
grunde bei vielen gruppen zusammen
besitzen
und genau das sind die beiden
ansatzpunkt für unsere überlegungen die
wir unsere werte verbessern können und
sei auf grundlage der publikation
projektoren mit einem vorhaben ein
blended learning vorhaben das auch so
ein wenig die angst oder die perspektive
der andere veranstaltungen die wir dann
im rahmen des kohleproduzenten
überprüfen sollte und die künftig nicht
zu punkten
großes ganzes in den blick nehmen sollte
und nicht nur einzelne themen unsere
haare so und dann fragen sie uns lieber
erfolgreich bei den alten griechen
kaffee und briefbogen zu entwickeln eine
nudel kurs der für das lernen lernen ist
dem grunde inhalte die in den
einzelveranstaltungen wie die probe
dortigen der eigentlichen politischen
führungen die ägyptologie und so weiter
immer wieder angesprochen werden
prognostizieren dem mond auch nicht zeit
haben das immer wieder auch wieder
abonnenten zu verkünden dass man das
zusammengefasst und in einem seltenen
übergrößen model kurs dann aufbereitet
so dass sich die studierenden selbst
tätig da noch gewisse wissensdefizite
einfach nachholen können somit einfach
auf der höhe
auch das kenntnisstand std voraussetzen
bleiben konnten das ist die grundidee
und ein eckpfeiler dass auch ein ideales
auf das inhalten
google kurs zu finden sind nicht
hauptsächlich von und scanner wurden
sondern wieder oben formen erfahren
studierenden unseren haustieren die
immer noch an ganz alten briten bringen
auch die schwierigkeiten und hören die
routiniers hamann finger bedienen sie
sich einfach konfrontiert sehen
und das waren auch integraler
bestandteil unseres konzeptes ist dass
wir im rahmen multiplikatoren projektes
kommen die 6
das ergebnis sieht dann so aus so einem
kuschelkurs der verschiedenen wissen
ebenen abdeckt das heißt es gibt das
fängt an mit ganz allgemeinen
überblicken und einführung der d q-cells
ist auch ein streng chronologisch
angeordnet um einfach wirklich nicht oft
muss er 5000 jahren das zu sanieren und
innerhalb dieser woche werden dann
verschiedene informationen in literatur
hinweise foren zur diskussion zum fragen
angeboten für die studierenden die den
voraussetzungen los sich diesem thema
damit zu bilden können
dabei wurden viele möglichkeiten
dann las ich suche nicht die
insbesondere des klosters ganze menge
das er umfänglich ist in dem adobe
schlüsselwörter fachbegriffe einfach
erklärt werden und im gegensatz zu einem
buch sucht der model selbst diese wörter
im text gemacht aufkauft legen und schon
wird es erklärt dass es eben auch eines
denn über mehrwert rede etwas was ihm
ein hoch so in dem der kürze nicht
bieten kann
um aber die bedürfnisse uns aber auch
faszinierende im subjektiven oder zu
vertiefen dabei informationen nach
zunehmenden zum schlüssel liegen dafür
gibt es nicht
wurden auch entsprechende vertiefung
themen generiert von dem studierende die
dann wiederum stufen war ich mal mehr
mal weniger informationen zu einem thema
wie zum beispiel seine objekte im
ernährungs stein der sehr wichtig für
die chronologie der könglichen
geschichte ist präsentiert werden je
nachdem wie viel information und braucht
kann man sich dann eben daran
durchklicken und diese informationen
ließen bundeskanzlers wieder im vorteil
dass das textverständnis wirken gleich
abgefragt ja aber das ist nur durch die
klingt das wie und das hat er wirklich
gelesen dass märkte dann selbst schnell
in eine automarke automatisierte abfrage
in den unternehmen das wissen abgefragt
wird genau das fehlte uns das begehrte
oder sagen wir so mit seinen kämpfen
gehabt rennen und das gute und das ist
offenbar systematisch das ist wohl auch
gestern zu machen gesprochen es ist die
sprache und akzeptanz des zusätzlichen
angebot ist war auch mir ist es so dass
das ganz das mandat dafür eben bislang
keine die cds punkte bekommt wenn man
dass sie sich zurück hieß es jüngst in
studieren und natürlich um bessere
ergebnisse der klausur zu erziehen aber
das zu vermitteln ist eine aufgabe für
sich so was ich eben auch aus einem
wichtigen punkt
was wir also ein bisschen
an sie ausgeschüttet habe andere
möglichkeiten dazu motivieren sich
dieses wissen zu erhalten und was auch
ganz wichtig ist die abfrage ob dieses
bisschen tatsächlich dann verankert ist
ist etwas was eben in unserer
ursprünglichen konzeption noch nicht im
fokus stand und das war dann unsere
motivation um ein projekt im rahmen von
deren zusätzen das aber eng verknüpft
mit dem ursprünglichen multiplikator ist
liegen offensichtlich werden also im
grunde darum zu motivieren ihr wissen
auf spielerische weise und mit spaß
abzuprüfen und was dann auch nicht
genügend motivation generieren würde
dass das angebot dann auch wahrnehmen
und was ist jetzt beschreiben durch
trifft im grunde die grundideen
umgegangen sind alles was die chromatik
angeht eigentlich informierte ägypten
technische umsetzung und so weiter unser
erster schritt war tatsächlich mit der
allzu grobe geisteswissenschaften in
kontakt zu treten die wir sehr gut
kennen insbesondere solche christian
riebel
der nämlich schon seit vielen jahren
bieten zusammen datenbanken also vor
allem die lösung für forschungsprojekte
realisiert hat und die archivgruppe hat
in diesem fall eine wichtige
mittlerrolle spiele das ist dies nicht
nur zu einem teil selbst in der
technischen umsetzung tätig geworden
sie hat uns aber eine gedacht vom mit
nämlich zurück und der besten acht schon
mehrfach erwähnt wurde und auch sein
seine bilanz vom backstage auf die ich
auch jetzt noch im detail ein oder etwas
detaillierter angehen werde
was unseren kunden die gestrige
veranstaltung
[Musik]
diese zusammen aber es kam dann auch
tatsächlich zustande
unter dem titel des tors 5000 jahren
lernen das heißt in frage stellen oder
die problemstellung ist immer noch
dieselbe und jens diesem grunde darum
das schwierig umzusetzen und es war
tatsächlich auch
verbundprojekt zum einen dann bestehend
aus professor gut kam und mir aber dann
dem auf zusammen da ein problem mit
herrn betriebe so gehören professor
brief an der informatik der krise an den
mitarbeitern und das ist
ich denke das ist ein ganz wichtiger
repräsentativer raum gewesen
die informatik hat dieses projekt als
ergebnis forschungsprojekt betrachtet
und auch die mitarbeiter von herrn
bringen vierten runde über den effekt
von bönigen analytics im einsatz von
leben genau die gründe dagegen backstage
bereits etablierten instrumente
informatiker zu nutzen um die planung
dieser plattform lernspielen zu
entwickeln und auf bereitzustellen
wechselt selbst ist ein instrument das
im grunde die grenzen zwischen präsenz
nicht und lernen zu hause durch die
senats dass die inhalte die auf den
folien in den vorlesungen geboten werden
den kunden für die studierenden sowohl
im unterricht selbst auf den endgeräten
nachvollziehbar ist also auch schon zu
hause dann noch nachgearbeitet werden
kamen und steht weiter bei ihnen aus das
wurde gestern von angesprochen
man kann eben in der von ihm selbst zum
beispiel christian bränden man kann ab
und umfragen starten
und dieses backstage macht es eben
möglich dass die in echtzeit ausgewertet
werden und so reduzieren
die institution de in echtzeit reagieren
auf die bedürfnisse der studierenden das
ist für die informatiker geben besonders
turbulent er zwar nicht eine handvoll
studierende haben sondern müssen den
anforderungen haben
zweitens ist die werden dort so
aufgebaut um konzepte erklärt und diese
gespannten sein
um dann weiter unterricht zu gehen das
heißt die abfrage ob das was gerade
vermittelt wurde wirklich verstanden
wohl ist da ganz entscheidend dafür
wurde wächst entwickelt und jetzt auf
die bedürfnisse der schüler losgelassen
und eine wichtige voraussetzung waren
diese implementierung der wirklichkeit
kristan zu bauen
das bietet intel in einem gewissen
rahmen und natürlich auch aber ein
entscheidender vorteil ist
unabhängigkeit vom backstage
das heißt auch wenn nicht studierende
haben und nicht in der lmu eingestiegen
sind ist das gar kein problem ist jedoch
die einzubinden
es ist zwar bei modellen auch
theoretisch möglich bislang nicht
gelungen mein studieren dort in meinem
kurse einzuschreiben
die eben nicht seitlich lebens in werben
auch sagen wir haben sieben studenten
die dann einfach der zugang versperrt
ist und dass es bei maxdata problemen
und wie sind wir weitergegangen einem
ist diese kunden daher neben diesen
diesen technischen voraussetzungen war
auch dazu komme ich gleich das
vorhandensein von größeren datenmengen
wirklich gewisse haben
konnten das zeige ich ihnen auch gleich
unsere vorgehen war eben so konzipiert
dass wir das zum einen informatik krise
generieren
zu diesen rechts was da als es in sachen
denke ja dass man denken sollte dass man
sie chronologisch einordnen sollte oder
auch topografisch kassieren zu haben
wurde der anja buchstein zum beispiel
gefunden so was sollten abgefragt werden
und wo es immer auch ein neues
forschungsprojekt ist backstage von
vornherein auch die möglichkeit der akku
für learning analytics zusammen dass man
kann daten erheben über das
nutzungsverhalten der kunden aber auch
rückschlüsse ziehen auf dem museum auf
gold und ließen rückschlüsse ihnen darin
auch automatisiert wieder zurückgeben um
ihn einfach auch um zu zeigen wo sie
tatsächlich ging und wo sie nach
arbeiten soll
das ist auch als werbung das ist
politisch gegenwert genau
grundlage war ein für die information
also dass das geologische oder
einbringen eine welle der gewalt ihrer
genannt besteht oder fast mittlerweile
über einen 14.000 bilder begünstigt hat
denkmäler form von großen architektur
komplex bis eben zum zuwachs oder zum
keramik also eine große bandbreite von
denkmälern die manuskripte luca einfach
mit ihm auch die situation sehr gut mit
der einkünfte look einfach in das
konfrontiert ist eine sehr grosse und
hungrig auf fülle von denkmälern die
bahn dann regen einordnen muss ich zwar
schnell
und das sind eben auch zu unserem
restaurant und genau das gleiche es eben
nie ist so mussten
der vorteil war am nächsten tag wieder
dass die daten selbst bereits von der
gleichen gruppe dass es nicht geschafft
einen improvisierten bar und die dann
auch dann wichtige hilfe leisteten bei
der beim transfer der metadaten die
tatsächlich schon vorhanden sind das ist
am ende ist es dann eben schon immer
sagen woher kommt das objektiv ist
wo steht es halt selber solchem material
besteht ist all diese metadaten sind in
dieser datenbank bereits vorhanden und
musste nur noch ausgelesen werden
untergegangen dass an den razzien probe
geisteswissenschaft gefühllos gemacht
und diese aufbereiteten daten waren die
grundlage für die informatik und darum
wissen zu generieren
es ist das ist nicht geboren denn diese
gefäße und gurken auf grundlage und
erreichen datenbasis zunächst
automatisch geändert dass man den
computer erstellen lassen
die meisten dann über 300 quizze
zustande aus denen dann noch einmal und
da ist der faktor mensch dann doch
wieder in ordnung ausgelesen wurde
messergebnis restituieren des guten
namens länder besonders geeignet sind
und diese sind gegen bereits spielbar
ich habe auch einen computer mit
gebracht warum es dann wieder pause
aufwendungen sie selbst einmal spielen
und wissen genau und es sind eben
verschieden mittlerweile verschiedene
chris typen möglich also zum einen haben
diese decken jeder benennen da wird man
einmal eine auswahl von möglichkeiten
musste gewesen
man kann aber das ist wie auch sehen
können entweder du musst in eine
richtige reihenfolge in eine
chronologische bringen
das ist auch schon realisiert und was
eben gerade entwickelt wirklich ist
topographische einordnung von dingen
wenn er das immer ganz entscheidend das
schöne daran ist aufgrund der bereits
forst und gefahren und metadaten kamen
dann auch keine abstimmungen machen also
milliarden bremer kann man sagen es
reicht die gebrochen zuweist und
mittleres raich österreich sowieso
weiter völlig fortschritt sondern kann
man zur nach dynastien frage es gibt
immer in einem 30 zu erhalten und für
die experten kann man dann eben auch
möglich haben wenn ich das hier wird
wirklich zu sehen
das heißt sie können ihre wunderbar auf
aa herabstufen je nach den bedürfnissen
der unterschiedlichen strukturen und
nicht im sommer gesagt habe auf den
arien
dass die perspektive die wir anstreben
sollten
sie können das ist der zweitletzte songs
der briten und thutmosis der projekte
genau das was ihr nicht missen lassen
das heißt 18
dynastie ergo österreich 19 das team
österreich und zwölf den us team mit
das lasse ich mich auch ganz zum ende
kommen
was sind die sozialen probleme e mail
die zumindest vorabend sie und inklusive
hoffentlich auch interessant sein können
für uns erfüllt dieses instrument zum
ganz wichtigen aspekt nämlich denn es
stellt ein wichtiges selbst lernen im
studium und das ist etwas was bologna
immer die studierenden klar war dass das
einfach mit dazu gehört dass der
vermieter nicht die gesamtheit des
wissens abdecken können sondern was man
dann wirklich selbst sich große mengen
an information aneignen muss genauso
durch dieses auf spielerische weise und
sind gewisse abgeprüft unter den
studierenden damit orientierung sondern
sie geben nacharbeiten müssen das ist
ein ganz wichtiger punkt dass die
gaddafi betont geld und es kann man eben
auf grundlage der technischen heute mit
technischen möglichkeiten weit von einem
teil was man kann glücklich durch die
analyse des lernen und verhaltens und
nutzungsverhalten sting der studierenden
diesen wiederum ein konkretes wo es noch
benzin haben was sie besser machen aber
auch natürlich dass es besonders gut
machen und sich ein kundiger
belohnungssystem ansprechen zum beispiel
durch die fotos behalten
so weiter und so fort es ist ja
mittlerweile ein etabliertes konzept
genau
grundsätzlich ist dieses tool das ist
für ungewiss selbst auch offensichtlich
geworden sein
das ist nichts was das die ägyptologie
beschränkt bleiben muss sondern es ist
etwas was auch wegen jedes fach
interessant ist dass mit objekten immer
so mit behinderung gehen was große
kränkung von akten wissen im grunde
voraussetzt
für alle diese fächer ist und das ganze
dann die mythologischen bot sich liegen
aufgrund dieser erschlagenden
komplexität und es derzeit aus dem
lassen müssen
besonders achten und das finde ich
informatik selbst ist dieses vorhaben
eben auch forschungs rennbahn dass sie
forsten und machen was wir wissen können
mit hilfe der nutzer und des projektes
da noch daten gewesen diesen daraus
werte können daraus schlussfolgerungen
zu ziehen und ihre instrumente dadurch
verbessern das ist ein ganz ganz
wichtiger punkt wenn der mann nicht
genug betonen kann genau vier prozent
jahre gibt sicher auch noch in der 65
zum beispiel solche oder in der der
einbringung sonst gewisse neben den
präsenzunterricht das muss nicht auf
verhinderten am roboter von zu hause aus
beschränkt bleiben
dass wir auch der ansatz von professor
von bringen dass er das ganze eben auch
wirklich in seinen vorlesungen einfach
machen wollte ungleich zu sehen ob das
wasser gebadet erzählt hat auch wirklich
verstanden wurde
und das ist natürlich etwas was ja auch
tage meiner war das was man dass wir
auch probieren könnten auch wenn wir es
in der form noch nicht gemacht haben
ein weiterer wichtiger punkt ist der
dass umsetzung dieses projektes in
zusammenarbeit mit der
medieninformatiker überhaupt hätte
realisiert werden können
letzte woche habe ich einen vortrag
gehört eines mitarbeiters vom 8
[Musik]
und der betrug ging auch das ist nicht
den rasant ist gibt der erste haltepunkt
theologe ein informatiker ist das ist
etwas was ich bislang was zwar
propagiert wurde
was aber sich bislang nicht was nicht
realistisch erstanden oder zielführend
sondern worauf es ankommen ist geben die
zusammenarbeit zwischen informatikern
und da den wissenschaftler die eben
einiges bestimmten informationen bieten
die daten gelitten und bestimmte werden
dann mit hilfe des tools realisieren
wollen das ist im grunde eine
zusammenarbeit auf augenhöhe das heißt
sie haben selbst gesehen informatiker
gewinnen aus diesem projekt sehr viel
sie sind nicht an einen dienstleister zu
geliefert sondern sie können dass sie
ihre alten erfolge nutzen ja problem
heraus forderungen habe ich bereits
anklingen lassen und da sollten auch
lernen spiele ein kranken die schnelle
akzeptanz er von innen mit angeboten
blended learning angeboten
das phänomen dass die gegen die pigs
kurz vor der klausur hat aber
währenddessen
dass die nur leid wichtigen benutzt wird
das ist eben eine herausforderung der
wir uns auch irgendwo abstellen
das ist also in zeiten ist man aufwenden
muss noch gerade wenn man sich bewusst
dazu entscheidet studentische
hilfskräfte innerhalb einer region zu
lassen
das haben sie selbst alle erfahren
ich denke nicht dass das unbedingt ein
problem ist er in unserem fall ist es
sogar so dass wir nach dieser war es
unseren studierenden unseren up trucks
kursierenden ein sehr personalisiertes
grundsätzlichen fall also was können sie
besser machen und texte verständlich in
einem gewissen sprachlichen niveau mit
entsprechenden gremien unterfütterung
aufzubereiten also das können ganz
andere situation als jetzt in
probiotischen lehrveranstaltungen wo man
einfach nur dann stark richtung aufzeigt
wie man das am besten macht aber man
merkt dass die stimmen problemlos
umzusetzen in dem fall können sie es dem
ausdrücklichen und wir gehen in den
tieren besser machen können und so hat
die zeit lieber dafür aufgewandt haben
eben auch nicht die chance auf keinen
saft was wir in zukunft oder fertig auch
anstrengend ist zum einen wissen die
jungs
ein kunde hatte die möhringen analytics
einem brand datenbasis zu lieben und ihn
auch die ausweitung des nutzers das
heißt man kann grund wirklich auch über
den tellerrand der universität erlangen
aufs maul schauen und dort das ressort
von frau professor amerika auf
es gibt ja hier auch ein göttliches
museum in münchen mit einem sehr breiten
interessentenkreis und für die die sind
zum teil sehr kompetent was der quelle
oder am leben und die welt wie auch
einigen tagen wird die zielgruppe zum
beispiel kann für solche gewisse die
netten spaß daran das auszuprobieren und
wir werden sehen wie wir das in zukunft
eher umsetzen ich danke ihnen für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]